I think income taxes should be like as
close to zero as possible and then make
the capital gains taxes higher if you
make with your hands awesome if you make
on your assets that is infinite leverage
with time so if you trade the most
expensive thing for your money then I
feel like you should get taxed less and
if you trade no time for your money sure
what do you think would happen if it was
100 death tax I think that billionaires
would become far more giving and as they
approach the end they know they can't
keep it and I also think it would change
the way the game is played but if you
were to imagine Life as a poker game you
get a chip and then you sit down at the
table and you're dealt cards right
there's all the other players around the
table and depending on the cards are
dealt and the skill you have you begin
to amass chips the difference between
this fictitious casino and the casino of
life is that in the real world you can
amass chips you cash out you have a big
lot of money you walk out the door but
in the casino of life and the Grim
Reaper Taps you and says you it tells
you it's time you have to get out from
the table your chips stay on the table
and they push them to the middle to be
distributed by everybody else like
that's when you realize that it was a
fake game with rules that never mattered
to begin with